[Music]
I think that there are a few other
cities in America that presents such a
striking example of what happens when a
city and a people have a big bold
inclusive vision of what they want to
become if you go back just a few years
and look at Birmingham Alabama in around
the nineteen 1960s in Atlanta Georgia
Birmingham actually had a bigger more
dynamic economy and really should have
gone on to be the center of the economy
in the business center in the southeast
because of the steel industry but they
also had a governor named George Wallace
and they had a police chief named Bull
Connor at about the exact same time
Atlanta had a mere named Ivan Allen who
testified in favor of the Civil Rights
Act a governor named Carl Sanders and
then later a governor named Jimmy Carter
that had a different view of what our
city could be and what the South could
be without disparaging the city of
Birmingham in any way if you fast
forward 40 50 years later to where we
are today the city of Atlanta and the
metropolitan region's economy is about
three times the size of the economy of
the city of Birmingham and their metro
and I believe that that is because we
had a bigger bolder more inclusive
vision of what we wanted our city to be
we had men like dr. Martin Luther King
jr. and women like mrs. Juanita
Abernathy and mrs. Coretta Scott King
men like reverend joseph Lowery men like
ambassador Andrew Young Congressman John
Lewis people that set our city on a
different path
men like Robert Woodruff the CEO of
coca-cola who folks hosted the first
integrated dinner in the city of Atlanta
to honor dr. Martin Luther King the
issues that we face today
I don't believe are much different it's
why we have a welcoming initiative in
the
of Atlanta to embrace foreign-born
citizens at immigrants we have the
second fastest growing foreign-born
population by percentage on the eastern
seaboard and we have a level of economic
prosperity in our city and our region
that is almost unmatched in the
southeastern region of the United States
and so I think the message is simple if
you have a community that is closed that
is bigoted that is racist that tries to
present people who should be a part of
your community as other in the long term
in the short term you will pay a very
high moral price but I think you'll pay
an even higher economic price and so
right now there is a struggle that
America about what vision of our vision
of our country is the most appropriate
and what we have to do is to break
through this fever we are on different
ground but we're not on an entirely new
ground they have always there's always
been times in our country where there
was a fight for what we wanted the
direction of our country to be the best
version of America is worth it a big
bold inclusive vision of America is
worth it but as president John F Kennedy
once said things don't just happen
things are made to happen so if you
believe in that big bold inclusive
version of America that America will you
get to come and be who you are and love
who you love and pursue the dreams that
you want to achieve and have a fair shot
at a fair shake regardless of your zip
code or place of birth you got to get
out here and you've got to fight for it
because things don't just happen things
are made to happen
[Music]